un plat simple en apparence mais qui une
fois en bouche révèle toute sa saveur
pour frédéric calmels c'est le secret
d'une cuisine raffinée le chef de ce
restaurant de cheverny en a fait sa
signature culinaire j'aime les choses
direct avec vous marquez et lisible
surtout facile après d'appréhension
je certains de mes chefs avec qui j'ai
collaboré m'ont toujours dit le plus
compliqué c'est de faire simple on n'a
rien pour masquer tâche est un petit
défaut donc il faut que tout ça juste à
44 ans le chef cuisinier vient de
décrocher sa première étoile au guide
michelin il concrétise aujourd'hui un
rêve d'enfant j'ai réalisé très tôt que
je voulais être chef de cuisine dans une
belle maison comme celle ci avec
justement aller chercher des étoiles une
deux puis voilà c'est un peu c'est un
objectif que je me suis fixé
pour y arriver le chef et ses équipes
ont travaillé d'arrache-pied dès
l'ouverture de l'établissement en
septembre dernier six mois plus tard
l'heure ces efforts ont fini par payer
c'est une pression une exigence tous les
jours on se met une exigence se réveille
matin j'aime aller aujourd'hui on y va
on essaie de faire mieux que hier
et voilà
penser le restaurant compte actuellement
trois employés en cuisine il mise sur
son référencement dans le célèbre guide
rouge pour attirer de nouveaux talents
il faudrait être au moins on va dire une
brigade de 5 à 10 personnes pour
vraiment remplir intégralement la voilà
la demande client et puis bien sûr
pouvoir travailler sur de nouveaux de
nouvelles idées et mettre en place de
nouvelles choses oui l'objectif du
restaurant est clair viser toujours plus
loin et a ajouté une deuxième étoile à
son palmarès